yeah a woman said that um a guy graped
her
[Music]
um
she um but it came to find out that she
dreamt it
was it was okay yeah she dreamt it but
he actually went to prison for it really
you went to prison for grape yeah but
how did they find out she jumped like
because i think afterwards like
afterwards he appealed and
have you heard of it yeah like she she
dreamt it did she actually believe it
happened to her though
i don't know i i don't believe it i
think i bet she just knew they must have
looked into her psychology
team also going to psychiatric unit she
would have got evaluated if that was the
case
that that would have been the procedure
do you think that she was like too far
like she started singing and she
realized it was a dream and she was like
too far in it and she couldn't she like
was too embarrassed to take i don't i
don't know but i think she should go to
jail i think any girl that like does
that should go to jail even if you
retract because you're like oh i'm sorry
like it was my mistake but remember
though